she's been called the patron saint of
personal protective equipment or PPE and
for hospital staff here in Brooklyn
rhonda rowland shear is definitely a
godsend like many Americans she became
frustrated at the hard time hospital
staff faced getting a hold of PPE
essential for working with patients
infected with Cova 19 unlike most people
she decided to buy the equipment herself
and then give it away at this handout
the line went around the block each week
her charity cut red tape for Heroes
gives out plastic bags inside our gloves
masks shoe coverings hand sanitizer and
other supplies given to anybody who
needs it we treat non-medical staff just
like medical staff because they're their
working people the maintenance workers
that are in the rooms of COBIT patients
picking up the trash bringing lunch yet
they're considered non medical workers
and I don't agree with this anybody with
a hospital ID gets free PPE hospital
staff are appreciative this is very
important because you're going to save
lives you're going to save us from
transporting anything to the patient and
from the patient from transferring it
unto us so it's very important it's
life-saving OBO supplies Rhonda gives
away have cost her more than a
half-million dollars money she raised by
taking out a loan against her New York
City apartment well everyone is very
happy with what they're receiving many
have told us that inside the hospitals
the demand for personal protective
equipment for exceeds the supply overall
is not enough there's not enough you
know
you know our hospital we need more you
know so it's it's definitely something
that's very much appreciated
a woman who has taken it upon herself to
help protect hospital staff one bag of
supplies at a time
Gabe Rose Ando al Jazeera Brooklyn New
York